Samsung’s Galaxy S10 is gonna be announced
at their Unpacked event on February 20th,
and there’s recently been a ton of leaks
surrounding specs and final design.
We’re expecting 3 different models, including
the S10+, which is said to be packing some
impressive performance specs.
The question for a lot of us is if the iPhone
XS is still gonna hold the crown for the fastest
smartphone available.
Hit that Like button and we’ll go through
all of the recent S10 leaks and see what we
should expect on February 20th.
Last year, in April, 91Mobiles leaked renders
of the Galaxy S10+, featuring a bezel-less
design with a hole-punch dual-lens selfie
camera on the front of the phone.
Earlier this year, we also saw images of the
regular S10 model, with a single-lens hole-punch
instead, and we’ve seen multiple leaked
images that basically confirm what the front
will look like.
There was also a rumor of the S10 featuring
reverse wireless charging, which was almost
confirmed by a leaked legit-looking render
of the Samsung’s upcoming Galaxy Buds sitting
on top of the S10.
The Galaxy Buds are meant to be a direct rival
to Apple’s AirPods, and yes, we will definitely
be doing a comparison between the two, so
subscribe now so you don’t miss that!
The S10+ is said to feature a dual-lens camera
in the front and a triple-lens camera in the
back, as seen by these seemingly official
leaked renders.
The cheaper S10 model would keep the triple
lens rear camera but switch to a single lens
in the front.
Both of those models are said to support a
fingerprint sensor under the display.
The even cheaper S10e, may not support in-display
fingerprint sensing tech, and will simply
have a dual-lens camera on the back, just
like the Note 9.
Now let’s talk performance.
Geekbench 4 benchmark scores from the Galaxy
S10+’s Snapdragon 855 processor have been
leaked, featuring a 3413 single-core and 10256
multi-core scores.
The Exynox 9820-powered model was also leaked,
with scores of 4382 single-core and 9570 multi-core.
Interestingly, those scores put the S10+ on-par
with the iPhone X from 2017.
The iPhone XS, XS Max, and XR completely blow
both processors out of the water, with a single-core
score of 4795 and a single-core score of 11,267.
So from those leaks, the latest iPhones really
don’t have anything to worry about, since
Samsung’s 2019 smartphone will most likely
pack these underpowered processors.
On top of that, iPhones are usually better
optimized for performance and RAM management.
Also leaked was some Antutu benchmark scores,
with the S10+ scoring 325,000 points, still
less than the iPhone XS’ record-holding
352,000 points, so the iPhone doesn’t seem
to have anything to worry about in terms of
graphics either.
Apple has been doing a great job of increasing
processor performance every year for the last
few years, so we’re expecting future iPhones
to hold the performance crown as well.
Back to Samsung S10 leaks, Evan Blass posted
a seemingly official image of the Galaxy S10
lineup, looking similar to a Galaxy Note 9,
except with a long and narrow camera bump
and the removal of the fingerprint sensor.
FCC filings also showed that the Galaxy S10
could be one of the first devices to support
WiFi 6, which has also been rumored for the
2019 iPhones.
So with all of those leaks, there’s no doubt
the Galaxy S10 will be a great lineup of phones,
packing some new tech we’re hoping to see
in future iPhones as well.
As far as performance, we still expect the
iPhone XS to outperform the new S10 devices,
and we’ll be comparing everything from performance
to camera quality as soon as they get released,
so make sure to subscribe for that!
What are your thoughts on the upcoming Galaxy
S10?
Let us know in the comment section below!
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one.